[Music]
from dungeons to creative wine cellars
secret rooms are always fun to explore
because you never know what you'll find
some of these were completely
intentional but stick around to hear
some stories of people who found secret
rooms completely by accident if you're
new here hit that subscribe button to
never miss another video and don't
forget to give us a big thumbs up now
let's check out ten bizarre secret rooms
found in people's homes wine cellar one
of the coolest secret rooms people
installed in their homes is a wine
cellar most people have a wine cellar
located in their basement if you're
creative you can find many different
ways to store your wine modern interior
design created brand-new ways people
store their wine this is one of the most
creative secret room types ever these
are usually located in the kitchen for a
quick access with the way it's designed
is absolutely amazing you'd hardly even
know it's there
just open the trapdoor and you'll find a
tiny spiral staircase but what's more
important than that is the wall with
built-in shelves where you can find
stored why isn't this just the most
amazing idea ever
what a perfect way to keep your wine
cool and out of reach for children here
are some more examples of what a secret
wine cellar would actually look like
this one is even located under kitchen
island and again creatively hidden away
from any unwanted attention we're adding
these secret wine cellars on our dream
home ideas list these look totally
awesome and are definitely pretty
impressive
of course wine cellars can also be scary
and sometimes you can even find secret
rooms you never even knew existed in the
first place but we'll talk more about
that later hey guys we are so excited to
announce we're producing our own
no content head over to the trendy for
the best DIYs fashion tips makeup hacks
and so much more we are sure you're
going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section you love to
hear from you see you there brick wall
another one of the most bizarre and
slightly spooky ways to build a secret
room in your house if putting it behind
a brick wall it automatically gives the
room a spooky vibe and a feeling that
there's something more than just a room
behind that brick passage taking these
secrets nobody else is allowed to see or
just a cool looking hangout space we'll
explore more examples of spooky secret
rooms in just a bit but first let's
check out a few examples of what those
rooms behind a brick wall actually look
like this one looks like it has
absolutely no visible door handle which
makes it off-limits for anyone who's not
supposed to know about this secret we
also found this secret brick wall door
which belongs to an engineer who turned
his childhood obsession into a career
stephen humble designed secret
passageways from brick walls and other
ordinary items you might find in a home
he turns it into awesome rooms that can
be used to store all your secrets out of
all secret rooms the ones behind a brick
wall are our favorite if you could
design your own secret room where would
you put it what kind of mechanism would
it take to open it and what would it
have inside let us know in the comments
let's get creative and build our very
own secret room dresser playroom if
slides in a house aren't your thing you
could always give your child a place
where they could hang out by installing
a secret playroom behind a dresser if
you have kids we promised they'd love
something like this we better hurry even
if two adults here that would love the
idea of this secret room check out these
awesome examples that turned a wardrobe
into a secret passageway that leads to
an awesome looking room it looks just
like a regular closet but once you open
the door you can see a unique playing
space perfect for a hideout these
parents even turn their wardrobe into a
real-life Narnia we love that it looks
like a regular closet on the outside but
once you open the door
you enter the world of Narnia complete
with paintings on the wall and toys to
play with you can also turn it into a
perfect reading nook so your child can
study or take a break in peace
it's a perfect hiding spot and a place
where a child can keep all their secrets
of course you always have to make sure
you don't forget about this hidden room
yourself what do you think would you
have a secret room like this in your own
room at the child we definitely would
and we turn it into a secret library
where we could chill out when things
would get on our nerves office bookcase
before we go and explore some of the
more spooky cases of secret rooms found
in people's homes we also want to show
you this amazing feature that's probably
every child and adults dream it's an
amazing idea if you work from home and
need a quiet space where no one would
ever disturb you why not build a secret
room with a secret entrance only you
know about and turn it into an office
space you've probably seen these in
movies bookcases that open and show a
secret room inside they're often pretty
scary but you could also turn it into an
office space where you hold secret
meetings and everything related to your
work on the outside this bookcase looks
totally normal well except for the
guarding statue on the right that kind
of gives away the secret but once the
bookcase opens up it reveals a pretty
big working space area ideal for writers
and those who live in a particularly
noisy house some of these bookcases come
with different mechanisms that allow
them to open people either have to find
the correct book and tilt it use the
secret passcode or even turn a big wheel
just like you would with any larger safe
pretty awesome right we'd love to know
what extra secrets people keep in these
rooms dungeon things are about to get
slightly more creepy we'll show you some
of the cases where people discovered
secret rooms in their own homes
and had no idea they were there when
they first moved in like this secret
dungeon for example after moving to
their new studio apartment this Reddit
user found a mysterious hatch in the
floor that led to an even more
mysterious secret dungeon he said he got
a great deal for the room so he moved in
without viewing it but he never knew
that his studio apartment held many more
secrets after opening up the hatch he
saw a bunch of items but the stairs that
actually went a lot deeper than he
expected
after going downstairs he noticed two
small passageways that featured dungeon
like rooms along with graffiti on the
wall he found a brick bench as well as
long corridors he even said he was able
to hear the neighbors upstairs the
secret dungeon was made of brick however
it seemed like no other neighbors were
using it for storage even though the
dungeon was built directly under his
neighbor's apartment
also found a British newspaper dating
back to 1984
looks like the dungeon was actually much
bigger than his own studio apartment he
added that it feels absolutely scary
knowing he lives above it however it
would probably make a good home cinema
or a dungeon party space crawlspace okay
this next secret room is pretty creepy a
redditor posted an interesting discovery
after saying he moved into a new
apartment two weeks ago and found a
hidden crawlspace in his attic attics
are scary enough but imagine finding yet
another secret passageway you've never
noticed before on the outside it looked
like the place would just be a chute
that sorted his water heater but once he
opened it he noticed it had a much
bigger space that also included a carpet
pretty bizarre right
it gets even weirder in the back the
space had a weird door painted an all
black the door was sealed with a lock
which had to be broken on the inside the
redditor found a space that looked like
it was completely soundproof with three
electrical outlets then he also noticed
a small black safe along with an old
briefcase which held silver ingots
envelopes with foreign money and two
boxes the boxes contained some old
jewelry and two watches then the
redditor had a closer look at the safe
this is when it gets really weird he
found a bunch of tapes with the word
know repeatedly written in the dust
after the discovery went viral
the redditor was asked to take down the
content as it became part of an ongoing
investigation creepy small living space
it seems like reddit is a perfect place
if you're looking for bizarre stories
from people who found secret places in
their home this next one really sent
chills down our spine it all started
with a picture of a bookcase in a
redditors parents bedroom seems pretty
normal right one day he messed around
with his brother and pushed him into the
bookshelf his brother fell and ended up
pulling the bookshelf with him once it
moved they noticed a secret passageway
behind it it had a dark spiral staircase
that seemed to lead to a wall about
halfway down they noticed a strange
crawlspace where they found kids toys a
white sheet and tons of candy the
redditor commented that this was his
Halloween candy which meant someone took
it from his bag and ate it in this crawl
space they also found a toy elephant and
a mysterious key after a few months the
redditor gave an update that the police
investigated the crawlspace and
discovered clothes and soundproof walls
according to the police the person
living there stayed at the police
periodically how
the only entrance available was through
the parents bedroom which means the
person had to break in the house and
access the space while nobody was home
unfortunately they didn't find out who
was actually living there but the family
was so creeped out they ended up moving
out world war two room if you're not
creeped out by now you will be by this
secret room some of these make us want
to explore our own house
to see if we can find any secret doors
that lead to dungeons or in this case a
room that was once used in World War two
a Norwegian student discovered a secret
passageway in the Attic he noticed a
hidden space completely camouflaged with
wood
you've never even noticed it was there
once inside the student found a small
loft like room with a desk he also found
a lamp a single doll shoe an alarm a map
of West Europe and a note written in
Norwegian language the note was roughly
translated to a warning that people with
a weak stomach shouldn't access the room
pretty creepy right reddit reached out
to a historian who explained that the
room was actually used for pressing
newspapers for a few months between
December 1944 to March 1945 after
several police investigations they had
to move but the police never managed to
find the secret room the historian was
also able to show the movie with the men
who were actually using the room he also
suggested that the warning sign was just
a funny inside joke the student also
mentioned they couldn't find out how the
alarm actually worked and the solution
will most likely be a secret forever
singer castle one of the most talked
about homes with plenty of secret and
not so secret rooms is definitely the
singer castle located on a private
island in the Thousand Islands region in
the USA the island with singer castle is
actually available for rent and if you
do happen to rent it out you'll find
plenty of secret rooms available to
explore within the castle the castle
belonged to Commodore Frederick G Bourne
who created secret passageways to spy on
his party guests
seriously this was the only reason he
installed so many secret passageways in
the castle one of these secret rooms
involves a spiral staircase located
between the wooden panels in the library
it sounds like something straight from a
fairy tale the staircase leads to a
corridor where Frederick could observe
his visitors through a metal gate
hidden behind a portrait the portrait
would tip back and Frederic would be
able to freely observe his guests
without them realizing where he is
the hidden passage also led to a wine
cellar just in case the guests chitchat
became boring seems like a perfect place
to escape to when you want to leave the
party right if you could build your
perfect secret passageway leading to a
room what would it be let us know in the
comments we want to see your creativity
and what you come up with slide
let's end this video on a positive note
instead of leaving you terrified this is
rainbow house located in London's
charming Notting Hill area the house was
put on sale in 2014 and people were
stunned by its colourful staircase but
most importantly it's amazing slide that
connects the upstairs bedroom to the
downstairs living room the slide is
protected by a trapdoor which makes it
an awesome secret feature who wouldn't
want to have an actual slide in their
house it looks totally awesome the
entire house was designed by modern
interior designers that gave it a splash
of color from the spiral staircase to
walls and the floor this house features
colors all around it even has a rotating
king-size bed but the best place is
definitely the slide the trapdoor is
almost invisible and can be easily
overlooked which makes it a perfect
secret feature every child would
absolutely love the slide has a direct
landing on the large living room sofa
which is also an interesting feature the
house also has a stairway which links
the bedroom with a large Terrace the
house was available for 15,000 pounds
per month but who can put a price on
having your childhood dreams come true
be honest would you want to have a slide
in your home that's it for 10 bizarre
secret rooms found in people's homes for
more videos like this one check out 15
secret messages in famous logos see you
next time
[Music]